okay we're
live
hi I've
been the doctors all
day so we're going to see if we can get
a little bit work done here in the
afternoon um
there a few things I want to do
today uh quick quick check of our
ablations
okay so these are not bad this is what
we get out of
carbs
okay and this
is what we get out of random
search so we can see we get far
fewer good runs with random search carb
seems to give us something
nice the fact that there's so many
points not anywhere near the parito
frontier is a little
concerning
um
definitely want to sort that out but we
will deal with that
later
oops
um yeah I haven't heard back from the
MIT folks on uh the stuff I did
yesterday for them and GPU Drive is
proceeding pretty well
so I have some other work to do at the
moment there are a couple different
things I can
do let me see what I can
go go look
work the public portion is just getting
Isaac gem working nicely with
puffer
um now I can probably get this bound
pretty
quick I'm trying to think
what I can do from there
I mean I could just get this thing set
up and running like puffer
po that's probably a decent
test andp get
I think that's probably the reasonable
thing to
do I'm trying to see where the Isaac say
binds are for
this lots of people have been asking me
about Isaac
people really like their wrappers don't
they oh this is actually very similar to
um how we do this with
puffer yeah this is very similar
sign accept for
this the fact that they are overriding
their buffer instead of setting
it I'm trying to think what's the best
way to start on this
um let me see how how far their training
code is
off from what we're looking at
I need this thing that they're calling
an
agent yeah so I think that
probably if I just get this bound to
puffer then it's pretty easy to
add the algorithm make
changes to uh like an individual puffer
train
file I can probably get this to train
way faster as
well yeah cuz they just have some EX for
losses and stuff that's
fine okay so
we go I don't know what's up with my
memory
here quite a few
different tasks
base and then
like knowing what my graphs look like do
you
think yes that is why why do you have
that as your value function coefficient
just stop tuning that parameter just
leave it at
0.5 yeah set that just hard set value
function actually link me your link me
your hypers real quick because I didn't
know you were doing that or if if I had
seen that I would have told you to not
do
hypers holy hell
there a bunch of stuff in
here it's really this is just like a
torch
end right where they're just doing a
bunch of array Ops so torch
was
fine
fine probably faster at 32 but fine
it's
fine it's fine all right so this one is troll
fine all right so this one is troll
right here this value function
coefficient is Troll and then um
um update epo's borderline
here you've got 12 updates on stale data
cuz 32 131 so four updates per
Epoch um and then you got three Epoch so
12 if your m is fast basically this
number should always be one I know your
m is having some speed issues so maybe
it doesn't have to be one but uh that's
enough F
think I'd be surprised if I set up the
epox to
three I might have done it because your
M is so
slow if your m is fast this is basically
always
one but yeah set value function to 05
and take it out of your sweep
stable let me go check on something real
quick folks
yeah that's exactly it just try it at05
and then if that sucks do a sweep with
it a sweep without it I mean
I think I just got to grab
this make a puffer
wrapper
and see what I can do from there
is this a pit
package God damn it they don't have a
pit
package it's a
pain might be ready for multi training
[Music]
soon so do they have a pit package
when are you going to be working on
multi- agent
stuff um this we like
either probably next week is what it's
going to be cuz I was sent one thing to
do before this
go yeah Captain I would suggest I would
highly suggest um if you want to start
getting into the science side stuff do
the uh The Continuous breakout pong as a
just a really quick thing because that's
going to help you figure out what's
going on with your continuous side stuff
and then I will I'll get you involved
with some of our
um our multi-agent
efforts that would be my
suggestion
oops nothing private but just I don't
try not to leak DMS out of respect
does not have
logging oops I almost l a bad
okay we'll do my all my training has
been multi discreet recently due to
continuous actions yeah so that is part
of our science side stuff right I fixed
breakout so it actually trains and we
can start running experiments on that as
well which will be
fun oh yeah we're getting one more box
soon so I think that'll free up one for
you uh cuz I'm going to buy the well I
don't know how long it takes them to
ship it to be fair but I'm buying our
test node with a 5090 I'm going to get
like uh our
initial like just our like make sure
that these boxes are
good it's pretty nice we'll get
um uh we got like a decent quoted price
on them they're going to be just over
5500 a box
nice uh
this shouldn't even be that hard I'm
just freaking
exhausted I'm trying to think about how
I want to do
a over 4our dentist appointment why is
my hold on am I not live on
X oh no I am it's just a UI bug
I guess I just have to install this
in if I just clone this in puffer lib
it'll work and then I can make a package
later
is X like continuously
disconnecting or is it just restream
being
offline
1450 I don't know what's happening to
the
stream not much I can do about it but
it'll mess up my
container I guess what I want to do is I
want to just
grab where is
toml I guess this is what what I want to
do is I want to make this a separate
wrapper
this and then you wrap this so you this
goes here
args okay so we'll figure out how to get
these
and
then we need a puffer native en
we do self.
single observation space
okay so it's going to be something like
this or something like this
rln this looks like probably what
kyung
yeah I'm going to have to sit down with
Kung and help integrate this
stuff quite a bit
here I want to get at least to start on
this
should be
this should be n
n
CFG file
basically we're going to get rid of
arbs the way puffer set up
and then here we have
physics I see all this stuff
what
this
and then this is now device
ID and then
headless okay so this is not as
bad now all we need to
do is figure out what files to add
right and what else do we
need motion
file and here's the motion file okay
deprecated is it Isaac Jim or Isaac
Sim that we
great I'm tempted to make a new
container for
this I could also just
install uh 3.9
this
oh
okay Isaac gem
today yeah we're looking at some
stuff no module dist okay that's weird
because this definitely
exists this exists in the I'm tempted to
just get a container for
this do they ship
containers cuz here's the thing like if
I were using Isaac Sim one of their
updated things I could just do
I actually don't know what's wrong with
this this is an obnoxious thing with
like
old shitty old packages
ah Python 3 Dev okay that's my
bad I don't usually have to install old
python versions usually we have stuff on
uh something somewhat
recent puffer should be just fine with a
High Fidelity
Sim I mean the main thing puffer does is
not be slow so if your m is fast then
puffer's fast if your m is slow puffer
tries to make it as fast as it can if
your m is just fast then puffer is just
fast okay this is NVIDIA Nvidia I'm
expecting okay to not be a pain in the
ass
surely Nvidia builds good
software like if you were to pick one
company to expect to build good
software oh less than 3.9 that's
obnoxious
okay that's really old
I don't need VMS piss
off let me make sure this is actually
what's going on here
oh yeah look at
that you do need
3.8 that's crazy
all
right so this should
work it's
Nvidia there stuff should at least
compile
okay
uh
cool so
now if I just have to get puffer working
on this
and then
hopefully we can run the environment and
start looking at
okay so that actually seems like it
works um
type object not why do we even have this
[ __ ] typed in the first
place and I hate I
hate typed python code like this
else and you just literally end up
deleting the bloody types
5.1
okay well maybe
now let me just try to install this as
is and see what
that welcome YouTube folks
currently integrating an Isaac gym based
environment seeing if we can get it
running in
the proper pip package
right it should be installed
is it not like does it not work outside
of the
importing I do I just need to sim link
it like the
there we go editable installs just
broken for some weird stupid
reason okay
Gem High torch was
[Music]
imported that's freaking
hilarious which after Isaac J modules
really
first torch is already imported
yeah yeah
no module gem
torch all right what's gy
Tomo but it's not set up as a package
you can clearly see
maybe it's just
this it's a separate
torch why do pip install
dot
instead ah there we
go so now we have gem
chatting with Kung here working on
figuring out what uh what he's up to and
how he can help with
questionable okay stick to Isaac gy not
Isaac lab
cool for
asking Kong what's up with the packaging
here this doesn't make
okay one second folks I'm just figuring
out what I can do because kung's working
in parallel on um on this code base but
it doesn't seem quite ready to integrate
with puffer
yet because it's not
packaged I got Isaac I got Isaac Jim up
and
right I guess this is what we're doing
then basically same thing just slightly
different
repo uh I think this one is packaged
already
uh yeah let's just do pip install dot
because editable seem screwy
so this is what we
want this this thing
here which is very
okay so this is actually very
similar um very very
I think we got a plan
here we got a plan
all right so what we're going to do is
we're going to take this
stuff
whoops take all this
and swap
these and now this is going to go
here uh I don't want to completely
remove what I did before though because
I'm going to end up doing something very
function it's almost exactly the same if
you look at
yeah okay this is exactly what I thought
it was going to be perfect so I just
confirmed some stuff with kyung um
it's just going to end up
being some custom stuff in the clean
puff Ral script specific for this but
for the most part this is just going to
be some Isaac's and bind work
yeah this is great this is exactly what
uh what we want to be
doing so I can't really say the details
of what we're doing for uh this specific
client but I can say that you know we're
adding Isaac uh Isaac Jim bindings to
puffer lib and we're going to make sure
that Isaac Jim play nicely with puffer
lib as a part of it right and all that
stuff goes right back into puffer lib
and is public so everything is
everything is fun
there and then if I look at this this is
the same pasted code I don't need to
change anything there
numm yeah this is exactly the same
code and then there's this vcas wrapper
which I'm not sure
about uh I could leave this in for
now I probably should leave this in just
for
now and then we'll see what comes out of
this
okay all I got to do I'm still you know
on the side here going back and forth
through K clarifying A few
things but pretty much it looks like I
just take this
environment I see what comes out of it
okay that's not bad
um I think that's
set now do I have did I make a config
okay so I think think
probably most of this is the
same uh obviously I don't need this
stuff
right and I do need to go
check what extra parameters this thing
has
yeah let's
see what this
has they get SIM
forams parse Sim
forams yeah but we already have
these then they got
args oh they do have a motion file
still is this a thing
dur okay so they actually do have some
stuff uh it's actually the repos are
very
like cuz I have to get the yeah
fire and then this is
num
M
that's
everything that is
everything so we got F num threads num
sub teams num client
threads
M's let me join there K just hopping on
the
stream great
okay so I got this I don't think we need
this anymore we do we have this par Sim
config
thing or
Sim oh this is still there yeah this is
still there I don't actually know what
is this is
Sim I could just leave
it right gy util
ARS where do this config come from oh
you just
passed
config so all you got to do is
this that's
fine we'll put this after the
assert it's pretty good uh one second
let me I'm going to be right back I uh
let me go talk to One
Thing
okay minor Insurance CLE after 4our
dental
procedure
hoi
uh wait puffer lib environment
from no this should work
cuz this is a pip package right so I
should be able to
import no module F hoi
okay
um see this is what I wasn't sure about
with the packaging but this looks like
it's
correct but there's no fiz
h.n really did I mess up the import
[Music]
uh let me
there there is no setup.py but there's a
toml
pixie so I have the package installed I
can import the
up I'm not really familiar with pure P
project toml based
packaging um there would be like a find
packages or a find namespace
packages in a in a setup.py
start
[Music]
with God damn it you're making me
install pixie
garbage freaking com
you know how dumb it is to have a cond
inside of a
Docker it's
like so
bloated but
fine
uh
okay now
Pixy pixie shell
they're killing
me okay so from in
here fix seash
I see so the dependencies are only
specified under
it and then not have the
packages I'm set
up is it this
this okay this is
garbage R fresh installing box yeah go
ahead K you can go ahead do a fresh
install I'm a bit confused as to how
this is working cuz the package is
building but it doesn't
have unless I'm doing something very
stupid
like it builds without
this but then it doesn't
have n
log in and log
out real
uh the setup.py looks
correct as well I mean the toml looks
correct I Haven I really don't use toml
that much
does this like link to a version of
python by default it shouldn't right
because the toml has the python version
right
yeah
something when I do it editable
does that do
anything oh that works so for whatever
reason doing it
editable okay
perfect I got it running without pixie
here um you have to install this one
editable which is weird because the
other one didn't work editable so I
thought there was a quirk with
3.8
um f no attribute recurrent that's
fine we don't need that we're just going
to
[Music]
um make got unexpected
ARS
God damn it broke my
Cuda whatever this installed broke my
Cuda
it okay
uh what do I do about
installed that installed
torch
okay so this is
12.1 Cuda
12.1 that's definitely
supported new pixie version causing it
okay cond tools are bad K I'm telling
you cond tools
suck but it's fine you want to use it
for now we can use it for now I'm trying
to figure out why this thing was broken
my Cuda
completely
um like what the hell did this thing
install that broke my
Cuda do I have to just reboot the
container I can try
that it should
seg
fault okay so this now I have it but
it's seg
faults
um
oops
Mar okay so this I got torch
working and then the seg folds
somewhere let's see if I can figure out
where it seg fults probably right here
right
yeah so right there it's seg FS so let
me figure this out
um here's our
config if the asset path is wrong does
it seg
fault because
these this probably needs to have the
full path
here RL device
cud and oh headless is
false headless should be true
go and now we get as I expected we get
the load
errors
so I guess I just got to patch the paths
here because the config path doesn't
include the uh the full path
route uh it was just cuz headless was
off
okay now we
have correct
path okay what's wrong
now
unsupported unsupported character config
file
fiz
X
slash is that the
SM uh that's not where it
is so where's that
SM
SMX where's that come
SMX oh maybe I just don't need to add
the asset file name yeah
look yeah that's it I just I I I just
don't need to add
that here it's just patch
the the route
directory uh this is probably my bad
let's
motion ar.
motion walk
pick slw walk
pick.
PT
boom and
failed to
import data
assets
okay so this
is it's getting this path from
somewhere let's see where it's getting
it from
see I don't see a bad path in
here uh so it's got to be
in
update Tomo so new pixie works thank you
very
nice uh I have it working outside a
fixie for now
though I'm just trying to fix the paths
because like it works inside of uh your
directory but it doesn't work
globally I'm trying to figure out where
this path is coming from at the
[Music]
moment fiz Hy MJ CF I don't see where
this is getting
added I don't see this in the
configuration a
tensors well no this is cuz it went past
the load
operation maybe it's in the in the file
itself maybe it's
[Music]
it and
see MJ
CF yep it's a
now for now I'm going to just update
I literally did this for people
yesterday
um yeah so for packaging side stuff K
this is how you do
it just this is like a quick hack you do
something like
this where you just like put the path
routes the absolute path routes in the
underscore knit or whatever and then you
can just like add this to all their
paths and it'll
work for now I'm just going to fix the
paths hard though
continuous
okay only continuous action
space let's
see single action
M's that's a continuous action
spice
sir hey Joseph what's good I'm uh I'm
currently
adding bindings for Isaac gem stuff to
puffer we're doing a little bit of High
Fidelity
control we going high
five okay so
why why is this being
wonder gym do spaces I wonder if this is
gym gymnasium shenan
assert quick question about Robo code
doing Isaac Labs my stuff yeah sure oh
is this uh is this tosen
yep great yeah no half the reason I
stream is so that I can answer questions
live so ask
away when you run Robo code does the
robot actually and
render uh it only renders if you run the
the demo for that so like
you
see this is what it looks
like so I have the C render demo set up
I didn't even add the python stuff
right but yeah this
is this script right here and you should
be good to go and you see I didn't even
bother like I didn't even clean up
memory or anything here
yeah this is a gym gymnasium
thing it's going to be hoer
lib spaces
box isn't that what you ran bash scrips
yeah bash scripts build yeah that's what
I ran
scrips build ocean Robo code local and
then Robo
code ignore the seg
fault my systems old
janky yeah you can see I can play it a
little bit it's very hard to
play but you know you can kind of you
can actually beat it just by doing that
spikes why is mine running differently
what your is doing
one too many values to
unpack
uh interesting
see this doesn't give you
infos when I run do slash it renders
fine when I run with
GDB it renders funny attached is a
picture let's
see H that's funny
uh yeah literally he's streaming now you
just check if I'm streaming it's like
it's this is the whole
point
um yes it's just not loading assets
correctly man I don't know why not but
uh it's you can see it's rendering the
text and stuff but it's not loading in
your asset files um um I don't know why
GDB would break asset
boundary I mean you can clearly see
there's a bullet here there's a health
score here a health there and a radar be
over there so that looks to me like it's
just not loading in the the assets and
actually if you look on rip here
actually maybe I can Repro this for you
real quick
render oh no now it does
this works for me
man I don't
on you can look to see if it's not
loading the textures
correctly um you should get right here
like data loaded successfully 512
512 resource Robo code PNG loaded
successfully
weird possibly vs code thing if you're
running through that I don't
know welcome YouTube folks we're
currently attempting to get a Isaac's
Isaac gym based environment integrated
nicely with a puffer
here okay
because I don't plan on multiprocessing
this can I do c to the OBS
I think that'll work since it's
internally
vectorized I should be able to just put
everything on
GPU
uh right they're npire rays
okay going to jump
off I do that I ran through vs code and
it showed me
might go talk to
him maybe I'm doing it wrong thanks and
have fun
yeah heavy tools have problems heavy
tools have
problems it's why develop everything in
[ __ ]
Vim console only it's just less [ __ ]
goes wrong
agents there's something screwy here
because uh this numb agent should give
me yeah this numb agent should give
me a bigger
OBS num
agents one okay so that's wrong wrong
where's this come
spaces
okay
observations let's return puffer lib
must return info as a list of dicks
right our API is a little different
clamp got numpy okay yeah that's not
going to
work uh so we got to do actions equals
Torch from numpy actions. Cuda
let's try
that we're making good progress
here making very good progress here okay
perfect so OBS reward done info I
guessed
right OBS
shape reward
shape gun
shape and
truncations
info ah and info has has some stuff in
it
R
terminate
this is probably from your rapper right
from kung's rapper here uh we're
probably going to want to change this a
little
bit episode
returns okay I'm a little confused on
this
rewards okay so I'm going to have to
help adjust this wrapper a little bit
because this is
not okay like
technically just for for an initial
thing I can
do info equals
like episode
return
me we can do episode
length I can return info technically I
can do this
and let's see what
happens but I think we're going to have
to fix that wrapper because that's not
that's not a correct computation of
got
in
oh yeah one of those
fun evaluate
send actions I assume the actions are
like the wrong data type or something
how the hell is the action dim 153
that's
here let's try this
so bad that it broke the
uh broke
uh I think I just have to run this on
CPU
right okay so we're still going to get
the device side ofert because it's
happening on the N
side
okay M VI's GPU okay I just got
to
[Music]
config got to add it
here use GPU
dot oh it's uh hold
on CI the
dash no attribute use GPU
okay now we get
our our uh
actions Max
actions for.
men okay so there's a
we didn't get the error out of this
let's see we should get the error
now
um
index 79 is out of
Bounce
interesting compute
this this
clip index
79 I guess I got to just like go look at
this
right uh I don't know where like how
this could be triggered
equal okay so
here we are obs
Max okay so we got some funky OBS here
right
but
yes self- progress buff
this
hoi data dict
zero hoi
data tape
okay so I think it's going to
be if
do I think we do
this is this it
okay we have this set to massive badge
size uh so let's reduce this now
like
faster first thing we
do how long does this take to AIT let's
see
we do usually
40 40 96
M's and then we'll do a mini batch
okay so I thought Isaac Sim was supposed
to be Isaac Jim was supposed to be
fast isn't
it why is it this freaking slow
environment this means that puffer is
adding like no overhead and we're just
waiting on the stupid Sim
okay let's try some settings
16 one does this do anything
slow how's it that
slow I thought Isaac's gym was fast
to leave this at what it was before
because
holy
um what did they have this set
at they have some good settings for
us
that's
sad four mini
or mini
batches update
EPO six which is
obscene advantage C coefficient
two value
false five
they got some crazy settings in
here this is a
five Max rad
[Music]
Norm
no
[Music]
and
Lambda yes these don't even look
tuned like at all this is just some
scientist that just like slapped some
parameters and hoped it
worked
um I can run it with this but
holy and they did 20 48m only as
okay I I got it running though um I
probably fix this episode return rapper
because that's
wrong
and then I get to ship this to
oh this is greater than
10,000 yeah that's crazy slow but they
say that
multi-agent okay they say that this can
be
fast um
fast let me just fix uh I'm going use a
restro real quick and then we're going
to fix this environment
wrapper and then we'll uh I'll chat with
Kung on a couple things oh I haven't
been checking my Discord at all have
I yeah one sec toen let me use a
restroom real quick be right
okay what can I
uh what can I do for you to send
going over the bot you originally coded
yeah it's a really stupid
bot I think I spent all of 20 minutes on
it
default seems to be one m one robot next
406 yeah so K that's not how Isaac Isaac
Jim Works fast so if we can switch it
cuz like we're not going to be able to
get anything done at 10,000 steps per
second right we just
not uh you were using the pose of the
other robot to be accurate when shooting
we won't actually do that right
shouldn't have access to the other
robot's pose only yes
exactly um so scripted Bots are allowed
to cheat essentially so we can have some
built-in scripted opponents that can
cheat that's fine but when we're
training the RL Bots they're only going
to have access to the observations that
they would get as defined by the
original game you know scanning radar
and all that
it's a very common way of building an
enemy AI is you just let the enemy cheat
it's pretty
okay got you program to cheat then have
class now talk to you later yeah thanks
to awesome good work on
this uh where's the thing with
episode all right so let me see how this
thing is is working at the moment um cuz
this is not
these oh also Kung I think that this um
this reset is wrong as well because if
they're all separate environments then
waiting for them all to be done right
now before I reset any of
them I'm not blaming you on this reset
rapper CH it's just it's wrong so I have
to think about
it I think it's wrong at
least Captain says finished a one bill
sweep did
better we flaw still slowly exploding
let me check can you put that link in
the Discord the uh the chat window is
broken at the moment the clickable one
is
broken I will take a quick second to
check that on list
before look at this this is still going
up over here this burst hit you still
have metrics that are going
up okay interesting with the value loss
well your KL is
not amazing
stuff to be fair your losses I was just
uh a puffer bug was reported all your
losses are going to be scaled
up oh actually maybe your value loss
isn't that bad Captain because I got a
bug report I haven't fixed it yet but
I'm actually scaling all of the losses
by a factor of the number of epoch and
you have multiple
epochs so if you have three Epoch
actually your value loss is only like
0.2 or something so maybe this isn't
that bad
0.1 I mean it's still slowly exploding
right
that the default and clean if that's the
clean RL default then it's
good oh actually your target KL being 0.
2 uh that's probably why your KL is 0. 2
isn't it or is it 0.02 let me
see no it's 0.02 never
mind so the kl's
fine ENT triy is very
low honestly I can't tell you if this is
exploding this could be stabilizing over
here and if this is divide by 3 it's
only it's less than 2 this could be
fine yeah all of them are going to be
lower by a factor of
three so you know I wouldn't worry about
it until you see stuff crashing so when
you see episode return
crash um that's when we can worry about
the value function
I think as long as you're going as win
rate and episode return are stable going
up you're fine for
now try to train for longer
yeah what's the throughput of this
thing performance
140 140k
okay can I resume training runs easily I
haven't tried I think you can I don't
usually you should be able to load it in
though you might have to fiddle with it
a little bit but you should be able to
pass it to
checkpoint I don't know if it'll like
screw with the WB graphs or what
though I really would like to get your
training up by another like 3x or
whatever because if we can get it to
like 500k then you can start running
proper sweeps I mean the thing is this m
takes long enough to train that like
you're probably going to have to run 500
million step
sweeps like at 100,000 it's kind of slow
right like it takes long enough to train
that we're going to have to run 500 mil
sweeps I was thinking we can probably
add some early stopping stuff so like if
after 100 Mil you know you don't have
point2 we can just stop the
runs um so that'll help some like once
we integrate that you could actually
help with that it's pretty easy
um but yeah
this burst hit is kind of good over here
you see like like you have metrics that
are still going
up it's good to log stuff like this
right cuz like if you like have shops
hit with a specific weapon right maybe
it takes a while to figure out a
specific weapon
this is good
though that's
K default
copied we said done m in clean AR
script okay maybe I N some SPS off of
good let me try
this I do have weapon specific metrics
in logs but I sum them in Python because
I haven't needed them
yet sum
them presumably you've looked at the
logging for some of the complex M's
right to see how to do
it okay as long as you've looked at it
and you're doing it
observations how about
this is
this good for
us or is this bad for
us shape the
mismatch cannot be
broadcast all right
empty
if indices
okay CH is there a weird thing where it
returns all of the observations even
when you just reset specific IDs
this cuz it's returning me a full batch
even if I give it
yeah internally reset provides
IDs but returns okay so it does
correctly though it does correctly reset
just the M's
for the indices you give it doesn't
reset them all for some dumb reason
right so this is
slower doesn't seem to change
perf yep
okay doesn't seem to change
perf that's kind of weird that like
early
resetting doesn't really change perf
well I will at least fix this return
rapper right now and we'll go from
there so
lot of
inefficiencies yeah we are absolutely
going to have to like put them all in
one scene or something because we're not
going to be able to do anything with
11,000 steps per second just like
straight up we're not going to be able
to do anything um like 100k minimum for
us to be able to like
function on
this and Isaac Jim is supposed to be
able to hit like hundreds of thousands
of steps per second if you batch it's
just not set up
correctly um you know for whatever
reason these GPU Sims like you have to
put all the robots in one C and it's
kind of stupid but I think we should
need to do that
because yeah this is
not like we can't do anything with 11k
SPS this is freaking slower than
Atari at least we get like 30k out of
Atari
episode do like this
then what we do
is the done ones here we're going to
have to
go so you you might want to double check
this
yeah I'm pushing this for you to play
with
k
um you should probably give me perms
[Music]
to
wait oh yeah this is all I changed
here um
would you like me to push this to a
branch or do you want to integrate this
more generally like all you have to do
to fix this so it works with both your
script and my script is uh do the like
the root path thing maybe I'll just do
that for you right now let's see it's
5:30 yeah I can probably just do that
for you right
now
yeah I should be able to do that
so also is this thing
training K I think that this thing is
actually
training the the return has gone up it
was below 0.04 when I
started
so I think I actually got this thing
training like zero
shot is probably probably not great but
it looks like it's going up a
bit I grabbed all the parameters from
the clean RL file I don't know how fast
your training is with uh with clean RL
it's probably pretty similar since the M
is so
I've seen it with clean RL
cool is this how fast clean RL runs as
well I wouldn't think clean RL would be
any faster than this it's 96% M time
unless I broke something in the
everything
similar cool I mean that's expected
right it's your hard bottleneck by the
end so once we make the M faster then
puffer lib will actually be able to keep
up with it whereas basically narl
please push to a branch yeah let me fix
your path first
yeah this thing is definitely training I
don't know how good it works with clean
RL um but this thing is definitely
training so you should be able to use
this for
this has sweeps and W be integrated as
well so
replicate well yeah I mean you should be
like we should be able to use this for
basically both code bases it's almost
identical
right like I have this pushed like the
code for ASC should be basically
identical to this
right okay I'm going to kill this cuz
this definitely works it's not logging
anyways
so it's it's just it's a similar thing
with a better code base but we are going
to be able to do the full thing
right do they have do they have
comparable numbers like are there
numbers on both of the papers to see how
good those things are
on okay well we got to give them the
thing they asked
for unless we have a compelling evidence
that this is
um yeah this thing doesn't like
strings we'll just do like that this
thing doesn't like
um doesn't like this we'll just do like
this
cool we definitely need to get some like
just some baselines up and running and
we need it to be faster than this
because like we're just not going to get
anything done in a reasonable amount of
time with training going at this speed
so I would say like getting this thing
if you can get the same thing loaded but
instead of having it be 4,000 of like
4,000 scenes with one robot if it's just
like the same robot at like 4,000
stations in one scene if we can get that
fast that's going to be very very
important plus that'll be good for
puffer right that's like that's the
version of Isaac we want in puffer like
this is completely useless as a
environment like 11,000 you can't do
anything with that
what do I run here
wait oh
cleaner I'm making sure that I didn't
break your
script well I didn't install all the
stuff but fine you can test this I I
doubt I broke your script it should be
fine
uh did you add me to this thing do I
have to accept
check where the hell is this
I does the check not
actually do anything or is it
just can you send it again I think I'm
not supposed to hit the
check maybe is it in my
email and freaking
changes oh there it
is got
it I got it it's just the UI was weird
if you hit the check mark that doesn't
accept it it just deletes it so check
means delete I
oops oh that's weird now it just works
all right cool so there's your
branch and uh you also have Isaac Jim
Branch on puffer
Li all right so that ought to work for
you ASC is 50k do you know is ASC is it
is that with
one per
scene or is that already parallelized
like all the things in one scene so I'm
pretty damn sure we want to put
everything in one
scene like there's a huge huge
difference between 50k and 500k as far
as what we're going to be able to do
with that like 500k means we can just
Auto solve it with aggressive hyper pram
sweeps 50k means we kind of have to do
stuff manually and guess
CL
1% no
fingers I
is it
this I don't
know I haven't seen others well that's
how Isaac Sim works right look
Isaac yeah look you see these demos all
the time right where they have like a
million robots in one
M I'm pretty damn sure this is what you
do like look you see they have like them
all in one M like this
I've seen this all over the place and
I'm pretty sure it's because the way
that the physics Sim works you can't
parallelize the GPU computations over
instances you got to do it over uh in
one map I'm pretty
sure that's only rendering
really then why is it so
slow I mean this thing is supposed to be
faster right
okay that's
slow I thought this is supposed to be
fast
cool we're
good so I mean that's
paper what's it called action something
or
it
this and
[Music]
then
paper this
one
comparable
benchmarks where's table
H fiz okay so that's a late wait I'm
confused there so fiz hoi is a later
paper so this thing
has I mean this thing has a better model
though doesn't
it this is like a better humanoid
model and then this is like a simplified
thing is
fingers this just has a
sword is
that it's just the render
ring okay so it's the
same ASC is a simpler okay so hoi is a
more complex so we got that repo running
is good
right
fingers robot
object but this is not for then is this
for animations what is this for physics
based
imitation this might be too high
fidelity
honestly this might be too high fidelity
though because
like this is like for
accurate object interaction this is like
too much just for animation right
got to make the training fully work does
it not fully work at the
moment I mean this thing
learns hey bet
Biz Hy is for
actual is it if I pull up the other
paper looking fit still not at all man
I'm down 15 lbs in like 3 weeks and my
lung capacity is totally
destroyed um it is not a good
time maybe may be but
it's it's pretty
is what they're using here is not
focused on like fine
grained like fine grained object
interaction this is focused on like
animation
as e oh I see what you mean yeah cuz the
fiz hoi is more fine okay yeah yeah okay
I I see you're
right
um it doesn't yeah I know X is GL X is
glitched today I don't know what's wrong
with
it started and moved on
okay well this is what we want to get to
we okay I'll figure out tomorrow to make
sure we're like loading in the correct
bot in the correct scenes and
stuff
um the good thing is we got Isaac Jim
bound
though we got Isaac in Bound to puffer
and you've started playing around with a
few different
repos getting training working and such
now it comes to my attention that this
is frozen so really this is the part
that we're looking
at is uh this like this is the RL Loop
right here
I don't fully understand
how the imitation and the RL data are
mixing
here
um I guess what I have is I just have
like a pure a pure RL task running right
but it is loading motion file so I don't
exactly know what it's
doing like I don't actually know exactly
what it is I have bindings for like
Isaac Jim yeah but I don't know what the
scenes and stuff were loaded in
do you know what the humanoid that we're
using is called I would like to know
what humanoid we're currently
using for both of
these you can find
that trying to control the
robot that looks like the input
motion so what the rln
is the rln is like rewarding you for
matching a trajectory already is that is
that what it
is is that their whole code base or is
that just the N is that in the N player
like the thing that I bound to
puffer is this actually like human
regularized is this like trying to
regularize towards a human policy or is
this like just some random Isaac task
yeah well not
falling so it is
regularized
okay we're going to have to get the
renderer working so we can play with
it I want to see what the heck we're
actually doing
ball playing lotions trying to match
okay yeah well we're going to need to
match that's probably not the type of
stuff we're going to want to match right
the point is if we've got the we've got
the Sim configured um they're like some
extra losses that are going to have to
go into clean puff so you can play
around with the ASC code base for a bit
and then hopefully we can get the ASC M
loaded into puffer and then added to
clean puff RL and hopefully we can get a
fast enough we can get the scene running
fast enough that we can do like hyper
pram tuning and stuff and auto solve cuz
I can tell just looking at the default
hyper prams um that they were not
tuned I can tell just looking at it they
were not tuned
DM
Nate
what this is only updated to python 310
really
me dude what the
hell literally their latest thing is
only
310 this is only 2.6k
Stars imagine passes
that all
right anything else for the time being
CH or we uh we good for now I uh I think
I've gotten the thing done I needed for
today
um probably going to go grab dinner and
then I might come back and start on some
oblations if I have any more energy left
for the
day it's probably what I'm going to do I
might come back and stream a little bit
later in the evening if I work I'll
stream it may as
well or I could review uh bet I owe you
some code reviews as well so I could do
that
yeah I got to eat first though go to
find the humanoid model why is there no
yeah K if you can just like send me the
basic obvious information that you would
ask about what we've done so far um that
would be great I think we've made some
pretty damn good progress for you know
just having been working on this for a
few days um you know but I'd like to
actually have a good sense of what it is
like this is all very confusing right
like this a giant package and it's hard
to tell what you're actually doing with
any of this stuff but it would be good
to get a just a few Basics anyways folks
I'm going to call it for now and then
I'm going to be back probably in like an
hourish
depending um hour and a half maybe and
probably we'll review some code for bet
merge in
uh one environment change one new
environment and we'll go from
there uh maybe I'll have some time for
some science side ablation stuff as
well waiting for one last thing from
Kong
confirmation and we'll call
it yep we'll give you okay thank you
yeah you don't need to join the thing
tomorrow it's like it's my job to keep
you out of
meetings all right see you all